[Musica]
[Applauso]
secondo di tre fratelli tutti maschi i
miei genitori molto giovani mia nonna a
dover gestire questo quartetto al
maschile anzi no c'era anche il cane
maschio quindi al 15 lo strumento il
principale strumento di gestione di
questo esercito al maschile era il
cucchiaione di legno quello dai mille
usi
tradizionalmente per mescolar cibo ma
anche per indicare per ricordare in
alcuni casi arma non convenzionale
lai riconosciuta
ricordo un'infanzia molto bella ricca di
affetto sebbene a quei tempi si si
mostrasse in maniera indiretta magari
celata in un gesto piccole rinunce in
una
in una merenda in un ragù in un caffè
a proposito di merenda ricordo quando
ero studente alle elementari e
cene in rito dello scambio delle merende
quel panino speciale il la merendina
nuova il compagno che non ne aveva e il
bullo di turno che veniva lì che tela
strappava via e ogni tanto il coraggio
del gruppo che interveniva e andava a
recuperare il maltolto insomma le
relazioni attorno a un panino e a una
crostatina scambiando le figurine le
biglie e con la voglia di giocare di
confrontarsi quella voglia di
confrontarsi che ho sempre mantenuto che
sempre cercato nel mondo del lavoro nei
tanti ruoli che ho avuto e di tanti
luoghi in cui sono stato in particolare
nel momento in cui ci si relazionava
tavola quel luogo quel posto in cui ho
costruito consolidato relazioni ma anche
festeggiato
riso e pianto in italia nel mondo
marocco uganda egitto stati uniti
passando per il medio oriente al di là
di cultura religione genere con tutti ho
relazionato a tavola in tutti i modi
possibili
dal ristorante stellato al deserto in
cui ricordo un momento in cui abbiamo
condiviso il cibo in un unico piatto in
dieci persone a una grigliata
particolare nella giungla di cui non
ricordo non so esattamente cosa ho
mangiato e francamente preferisco non
saperlo
fino al cairo dove mi sono rifugiato
presso amici nel bel mezzo della
primavera araba durante i fatti di
piazza tafel
più o meno un anno prima rispetto a
quest'ultimo episodio era il 2010 quando
alla ricerca di nuove strategie per per
il mio business e sono entrato in
contatto con la più grande
organizzazione al mondo di marketing
relazionale
per chi non lo conoscesse è quel sistema
per coltivare relazioni di fiducia e per
poter arrivare a scambiare opportunità
di business che all'inizio ho scelto
queste strategie queste tecniche per il
mio di business ma di lì a poco dopo
pochi mesi ho scelto di farne la mia
strada
imparare dai migliori al mondo ogni
tecnica ogni strategia per poi
applicarla e divulgarla in italia
in uno dei tanti momenti di formazione
in california dal cosiddetto padre del
network i moderno a ivan meitner gli
chiesi
cosa ne pensi del fare networking a
tavola
lui sorrise e mi disse claudio fare
networking non è fare eating e anche
drinking però particola battuta si
mostra molto interessato alla mia tesi
per cui se è vero che con metodo
struttura strategia si può passare da un
passaparola occasionale un passaparola
strutturato e da relazioni superficiali
a solide relazioni di business dovrebbe
essere altrettanto importante porre la
massima attenzione a tutti quei momenti
in cui ci si relaziona tavola e alla mia
domanda specifica se qualcuno avesse mai
trattato l'argomento con attenzione mi
rispose no e quindi una vocina e me
disse è la tua occasione
e allora inizia a intervistare migliaia
di imprenditori di lì ai successivi nove
anni e ciò che emerso è stato
innanzitutto la voglia della maggior
parte degli intervistati di relazionarsi
a tavola
e allora iniziai a catalogare le loro
risposte e le mie impressioni e sulla
base di quei dati
a fare delle considerazioni da cui ho
tratto un idea e poi un metodo
per strutturare il nutrire alla
relazione l'ho chiamato refero al test
adesso vorrei condividere con voi
qualche accenno su almeno tre punti
partendo proprio da un caffè primo in un
incontro di relazione a tavola il dove è
fondamentale quindi l'attenzione al dove
l'attenzione al dove immaginiamoci un
ristorante quindi avete un incontro in
un ristorante di milano è assolutamente
differente dal centro di milano magari
alla periferia di parma
l'accessibilità ci troviamo in una zona
a traffico limitato
c'è la possibilità di raggiungere la
location con mezzi propri mezzi pubblici
ci sono barriere architettoniche a
limitarci queste sono solo alcune delle
variabili da tener presente giulio
assiduo frequentatore di un bar del
centro storico della città al suo dire
il miglior caffè al mondo e quindi per
degustare questa prelibatezza ci fece
fare oltre un chilometro a piedi
peccato che le mie due colleghi avessero
i tacchi alti o per lui non era
importante per lui era solo un caffè
e ancora attenzione agli argomenti da
trattare
parlare comunque liberamente tenendo
presente chi hai di fronte
e gli obiettivi condivisi
mauro appassionato cacciatore sempre
pronto a raccontare tutti gli aneddoti
di caccia nei minimi particolari
e lo fece anche quel pomeriggio
peccato che eravamo con 2 persone
dichiaratamente animaliste nostri
potenziali clienti rimasti potenziali ma
anche per lui era solo un caffè
e poi ancora l'attenzione alle verifiche
raccogliere comunque sempre più
informazioni possibili per poterci
relazionale per potersi curare delle
relazioni ma tanto importante
raccogliere le informazioni quanto
verificarle
laura sempre stata attentissima a
al singolo minimo particolare e sapendo
dei miei problemi gastrointestinali si
guardava bene dal dall offrirmi un caffè
mai un quel periodo stavo bene e
francamente un buon caffè quel giorno
l'avrebbe voluto più che volentieri e
caffè arrivarono è profumatissimi per
tutti tranne che per me che sorseggiare
una tisana
ma anche per laura nonostante la sua
cura solo un caffè
vedete anche partendo da una abitudine
semplice come prendere un caffè
abbiamo analizzato alcune piccole
variabili che possono modificare o
stravolgere l'esito di un incontro e
questo impattare sulla relazione
il faro che guida il viaggio in questo
metodo è rappresentato dalla regola di
platino del dottor toni alessandra che
recita testualmente tratta gli altri
come vogliono essere trattati loro
come vogliono essere trattati loro e
questo ci guida in un percorso di
accoglienza di ascolto
per poter arrivare
a un giusto approccio e a scelte
consapevoli
ma questo non basta va abbinato
l'ascolto attivo
perché funzioni correttamente va
abbinato un ascolto attivo ascolto
attivo che è tra l'altro il il mettersi
in accoglienza imporsi in accoglienza il
sintonizzarsi tanto sui contenuti quanto
sue ragioni e sentimenti
nel raccogliere queste interviste e
verso qualcos'altro qualcosa di
veramente illuminante
nutriamo noi stessi e gli altri
in modi e tempi di cui non ci rendiamo
conto e lo sto parlando solo ed
esclusivamente del cibo tangibile
solido liquido che sia
una parola gentile
la giusta parola in un silenzio un
silenzio in accoglienza la musica che ci
fa sognare
ma anche una pacca sulla spalla un
sorriso tutti ingredienti con cui
nutrire la relazione e ce ne siamo
accorti
tanto lo scorso anno durante il primo
lockdown
in tanti oltre al dramma della pandemia
hanno vissuto momenti di paura e
solitudine
in quei giorni in tanti di noi hanno
imparato anche di utilizzare in maniera
differente in alcuni casi più intensa
strumenti di comunicazione online anche
per momenti conviviali e quindi abbiamo
avuto le colazioni online abbiamo avuto
gli aperitivi con gli amici online e i
pranzi e le cene in famiglia
ne ricordo una cena in particolare una
cena
con un amico
un amico che era in grande difficoltà in
quel momento è che abbiamo scelto di
invitare a cena in famiglia
in quella modalità
ricordo soprattutto ciò che mi ha detto
il giorno dopo sono stato lì ero con voi
abbiamo condiviso tutto
tutti gli ingredienti
sono tanti gli ingredienti di cui ci si
nutre
alcuni sono molto particolari
altri sono addirittura magici
l'ingrediente magico per eccellenza
quello che non dovrebbe mai mancare in
ogni pietanza in ogni ricetta in amore
l'amore che è vita e può rendere
speciale ogni forma di nutrimento
la mia mamma che per prima mi ha nutrito
mi ha insegnato a fare le cose con cura
ea mettere quel magico ingrediente
in ogni pietanza in ogni azione
comunque
nei primi mesi di quest'anno abbiamo
avuto modo di prenderci un caffè al volo
insieme
dedicarci qualche attimo un caffè che
che conteneva più del solo caffè c'era
quella col ti voglio bene che non siamo
mai riusciti a dirci fino in fondo
quegli abbracci
oggi lei mi guarda e sorride ma da altri
luoghi
ma c'è ancora e me il suo ingrediente
magico
che magari
ritrovo anche qui
nella roma di questo caffè
vi invito a sperimentare
che cosa vi fa stare bene
raccontatelo che cosa vi fa stare bene
cosa mangiate per festeggiare
che peccato di gola vi concedete per per
farvi una coccola magari in un momento
un po così
che cosa condividete in un momento
goliardico con gli amici e con le amiche
dove invitate il vostro miglior cliente
il migliore amico
e ancora come nutrite il vostro tempo
libero
sport
natura
arte
musica
che cos'altro
aggiungete un po di ingrediente magico
ovunque
nutrite voi stessi e nutrite gli altri
con amore
entrando in armonia gli uni con gli
altri
entriamo nei armonia col mondo intero e
tutte le creature che lo abitano
nutrire la relazione
cambia la vita anche partendo da un
caffè
grazie mamma
[Applauso]